Pulitzer prize-winning author Herman
woke once wrote within the rectilinear
boundaries of a hundred and 14th Street
and one hundred and twentieth Street of
Broadway and Morningside Drive there is
a peaceful oasis of the life of the mind
defiantly independent of the surrounding
marketplace racket the Manhattan the
best things of the moment were outside
the rectangle of Columbia the best
things of all human history and thought
were inside if only you had the sense
you could spend four years in an
unforgettably exciting and improving
alternation between two realms of magic
that doubled magic there's lasting me a
lifetime
all my writings such as they are trace
back in one sense or another to my four
years at Columbia